okay let's get right into audience
questions for the week there are some
good ones first one hey David did you
see bob lazar on Joe Rogan are his
claims about UFOs credible do you
believe him I did see this and I watched
this with great interest so if you're
not familiar with this there's a guy
named Bob Lazar who was on Joe Rogan's
program a week or two ago and Bob Lazar
is now about 60 years old and he says
he's a physicist that he worked on
extraterrestrial technology including
flying saucers he were trying to reverse
engineer this supposedly alien
technology at a place near called s4
near the area 51 location in the United
States Southwest and not only was he on
Joe Rogan recently there's a Netflix
documentary about him now and I watched
the documentary and I watched the
interview on Joe Rogan and what's
stunning and interesting about this
particular guy compared to some other
UFO people making claims about UFOs and
extraterrestrial technology is that he
is so easily able to talk about what
seemed like such specific details that
would be really difficult to make up
like if he didn't really do this stuff
if he didn't really see this stuff it
would be hard for him to so articulately
and specifically and consistently talk
about this material he says very clearly
what he does remember and things that he
doesn't remember him sometimes people
say you know if he was just making it up
he would always have answers or it would
seem more difficult for him to recall
supposed details he was really specific
about where was he and wasn't he allowed
into when he was working at this
location he explains in great detail how
gravity fields and element 115 and all
sorts of things work and I admit it's
interesting and it's compelling to watch
him talk about it in the documentary and
with Joe Rogan but I got a ton of people
asking me do I believe the substance of
what he says because he seems so
convincing and if it's true then the
government has been carrying out this
massive cover-up operation about the
fact that we have alien spacecraft and
technologies that are not of this world
which would be a massive massive
revelation and a scandal and say
as a sort of defense of a lot of the
things that Bob Lazar talked about more
generally in terms of technology include
things that he talked about which have
since become realities or have been sort
of he's been vindicated hand scanners
elements of wave theory have been proven
true over the years and in the
documentary he also says that he was
raided by the FBI
while the documentary itself was in
production which would again suggest
that there is a government effort to
cover up his ability to tell the story
the truth about what he's been involved
in now it's important to recognize that
there's no actual evidence or paperwork
or video or anything that confirms law
enforcement was at his place or raided
him I mean nothing is presented and I
think that's an important starting point
for our conversation so in the end I
don't believe the specifics of what Bob
Lazar is saying and I want to be clear
I'm not saying that we are alone in the
universe I don't know that to be true
mathematically there's a very compelling
case for there being alien life
elsewhere in the universe that's not
what I'm saying what I'm saying is that
the Bob Lazar claims for me have very
quickly become sort of these
conspiracies conspiracy things where
absence of evidence is interpreted as
actual evidence so as an example there's
no evidence of the FBI raid that he
claims happened this is seen by those
who believe Bob Lazar that clearly the
raid happened and was covered up and all
evidence of it was removed Occam's razor
would suggest that he simply made it up
the simplest explanation for why there
was no evidence for that raid is that it
didn't happen along the same lines
there's no evidence that Bob Lazar went
to school at the places he claims he
went to school the documentary and the
Rogen interview suggests that he did get
these degrees from the places he claims
but in order to discredit him there's
been a campaign to erase all evidence of
him having attended those schools
transcripts and admissions records were
deleted people who attended the schools
at the time he claims to be there
been gotten to and that's why they're
saying they have no recollection of Bob
Lazar going there it's a cover-up to
hide the fact that he's really educated
in physics again Occam's razor suggests
that the simplest explanation is the
best one which is he simply made it up
there's no record of him having attended
those schools because he didn't when you
go further and you look into Bob
lazarre's claims about gravity and
whatever else there are plenty of actual
people we know to be physicists who
debunked the stuff that he says now I
can't possibly debunk every scientific
claim Bob Lazar makes nor would it be
relevant because people who believed it
would just come up with new explanations
as to why he's believable but as an
example Lazar claims that one of his
vindications is that science has now
determined gravity to be a wave which
he's been saying for a long time and a
lot of the stuff he says about the alien
propulsion systems depend on that actual
physicists just don't agree with that
premise they say there is one theory
about gravity general relativity which
says gravity is neither a particle nor a
wave there are things called
gravitational waves but actual
physicists widely say that even the way
that Bob Lazar was setting up the
conversation about gravity is wrong but
when you watch it it seems so compelling
and he seems so articulate about this
stuff that people do get pulled in so
long story short without diagnosing
anyone I've spoken to my dad about this
extensively who's a mental health
professional and generally about these
not about Bob Lazar specifically but
I've spoken to him generally about these
folks who sound so smart and they seem
so grounded and yet they talk about
these wild topics but seems so normal
without anything else unusual going on
with them you talk to them about sports
or politics or whatever and they just
seem with it why is it that they
wouldn't be believable about this one
area whether it's aliens or whatever
else there's a condition called para
Freni a-- okay that might apply to some
of these folks I'm not even pretending
to diagnose Bob Lazar I'm merely telling
you there is a condition that explained
this and para Frannie as a condition
which is characterized by a very
organized system of delusions that
sometimes include paranoia sometimes
there are hallucinations often auditory
and sometimes there are not so you don't
even need to believe or argue about
whether the person believes the things
they say themselves or they're just
making it up para Freni a-- notably
doesn't come with that deteriorating
intellect or the personality issues that
lots of schizophrenic people do
experience when schizophrenic people get
serious schizophrenia they often start
to behave in ways that generally don't
make sense you meet them you can't have
a conversation with them about sports or
politics or whatever their entire
intellect and personality become
compromised with para Freni a-- you will
much more commonly have people who don't
act strangely or hold bizarre out of
this world for lack of a better term
beliefs except for this one area and one
thing that is often a part of para Freni
ax is the belief of being persecuted
that paranoia also is is often common in
schizophrenia which is right there in
bob lazar story right he claims to have
been raided for the FBI there's no
evidence that that raid took place he
believes he's being surveilled he won't
talk about element 115 with an earshot
of phones that have the battery in them
because he believes that it's possible
that he is being surveilled there so to
be clear I'm not saying Bob Lazar is
para phrenic what I'm telling you is
that there are simpler explanations for
these things which sometimes should be
considered and I don't find Bob Lazar
story particularly compelling tell me
where I'm wrong one of today's sponsors
is impeach the card slap game you cannot
slap Donald Trump in real life but you
can slap him in this hilarious
fast-paced two-player card game and you
can get it for ten percent off when you
go to david pakman.com slash impeach and
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word awesome for
parties when you're having a few drinks
I've been playing it with some friends
of mine currently has a 5 out of 5 star
rating on
and it combines clever satire about the
Trump administration with really funny
high-quality cartoon artwork all in a
really lively card game that's easy to
learn but it stays interesting every
time you play it because of how well
designed it is and really how much
thought went into the humor and the
political commentary the game covers a
ton of themes global warming Russian
collusion tax cuts for the wealthy
impeach the cards slap game is perfect
if you're looking for something fun and
casual to do with your politically
minded friends or family members you
might even learn something new about the
Trump administration while you're
playing the game it's a perfect gift for
anyone who has a sense of humor about
Trump or get it for yourself and have a
really fun and witty game to play when
people come over you can even play it
tournament style get impeach the cards
slap game by going to david pakman.com
slash impeach and get 10% off when you
use the coupon code pakman show at
checkout all one word